the images were heartbreaking five years
ago thousands killed hundreds of
thousands forced to flee to neighboring
bangladesh the stories they told of
indiscriminate killing rape and arson
now the united states has given a name
to what the world witnessed genocide and
crimes against humanity promising a
million dollars to help investigators
gather the evidence efforts are moving
forward not only at the international
court of justice
but also through the international
criminal court and through the domestic
courts of argentina in a case brought
under universal jurisdiction
the day will come when those responsible
for these appalling acts will have to
answer for them
and the u.s secretary of state seemed to
link the attack against the rohingyas to
the coup and the violence the military
continues to inflict on its citizens
which experts say could have an impact
it means that there's going to be
accountability for what they're doing
now now this may matter to some of the
generals that may not matter to men
online because i think his days are
numbered but um
it may matter to plenty of the others
and and it may
encourage more defections
at the united nations monday warnings
that it is getting worse
i regret to inform you that since my
last report to this council the human
rights situation in myanmar has not only
failed to improve it has deteriorated
significantly
in fact the myanmar hunter's war against
the people of myanmar has intensified
more than 1600
civilians have now been killed by the
hunter nearly 10 000
arbitrarily detained more than half a
million have been displaced the u.s
designation is likely a signal that they
will look to place more sanctions on the
leaders of myanmar in the coming months
it also sends the message to western
companies that they should rethink doing
business in myanmar just one step in
what will likely be a long and uncertain
path to justice
patty culhane al jazeera washington